enfant du cantal cet honneur de ce
département dans la paisible commune de
montboudif que naquit le 5 juillet 1911
georges pompidou
dès sa naissance il était confiée est
pris en nourrice par madame estier âgé
aujourd'hui de 83 cents quand le petit
est né on m'a téléphoné alors je suis
allé chercher à mon rythme je suis resté
calcul ou et puis je suis revenu chez
moi avec monsieur pompidou et le père de
ma compagne et moi et sa maman était
d'aller à l'école elle était nommée
est-il si elle ne peut pas de monsieur
pompidou était professeur à mullah c'est
un enfant un futur très bien bien gentil
bien mignon bien gros tour il avait tout
pour se faire aimer vous le dis bien où
je l'aimé je l'aimé comme les miennes
regardez combien de temps et combien
j'exige un mois et demi dans la nuit un
an et demi elle a admis oui je n'achète
pas encore cependant lorsqu'il vous
acquittez et vous pensé quitter tout le
monde pleurait moi je prenais le petit
peu aussi pleuré aussi est alors après
on sait qu avait annoncé que longtemps
jusqu'à quand la guerre a éclaté presque
puisque les arguments aussi j'achèterais
un peu arrêté là aujourd'hui vous êtes
très heureuse exige c'est très heureux
d'avoir mis en entendant mes bras
georges pompidou qui aujourd'hui est
devenu un homme d'état et j'en suis très
heureuse vous avez fait rire aussi
oui j'ai fait la prière relaté en coin
mais là en scène d'antoine de la chevade
drap comme une passante en pâte pour que
monsieur pompidou au régime dans ses
appels en seconde intention et moi je le
félicite
[Musique]